- [Kelly] Well I know
as I mentioned earlier
we have some of our most
memorable rad humans here
to share in this special event today
'cause I didn't wanna hog you for myself.
- (laughs)
- [Kelly] I'm Southern, I share.
So they have some questions for Dr. Biden.
Let's start with Dr.
Patrick a fellow educator.
- Oh, okay.
- Like the First Lady.
- He is the founder of
Man Up Teacher Fellowship.
- Oh, I know Man Up.
- Oh, you do? Oh awesome!
Well it's an organization
that we highlighted
that encourages more men of
color to become teachers.
So Dr. Patrick, what would
you like to ask Dr. Biden?
- Call me Jill.
- Hi Jill, hi Dr Biden.
- It feels odd, I can't do it either.
- [Dr. Patrick] I know yeah.
I thank you for being an advocate
for educators and for education.
We are thrilled to have an educator
in the white house and I'm truly humbled
and certainly proud to
get to meet you today.
- [Jill] Thank you.
- [Dr. Patrick] My question for you is
as an educator and a parent
what is your message
to teachers and parents
struggling with the toll
the pandemic is taking
on their children.
- [Jill] Yeah, it has
been so tough you know
and I see it in my own classroom,
on zoom of course.
But you know it's been
really hard for teachers
and parents and kids.
And I think that we're all struggling and
I think when we get
back into the classroom,
you know mental health is
going to be a big issue.
We gotta help heal these kids
and you know yourself I mean,
kids have been dealing
with food insecurity,
domestic violence, child abuse
so many things that they're going to be
bringing back with them into the classroom
and teachers are gonna need help
and that's one of the
things I love about Joe.
I love about those dinners at night.
I can say to him, "Joe, we need this,
you got to do this we're counting on you.
The teachers are counting on you."
And so,
that's why I keep saying
we got to have hope
because things will be better.
We're going to be back
in those classrooms.
There's going to be broadband.
I mean, I'm just so excited about,
you know the direction that
education is going to take
because we have to look at this
pandemic like an opportunity
to change the things
that didn't work, right?
That's what we're going to do
- Absolutely.
- [Jill] As teachers,
that's what we're going to do, yeah.
- [Kelly] I think that you're right.
See the mental health thing is going to be
like just with my four and six year old.
Like it's incredible and
all the different ages
and it was so funny just
to add in a little bit,
my mother who's also a teacher.
I'm actually a songwriter because of her.
Like I had a problem with
mental illness when I was a kid
I just was very much an introvert.
I know it's hard to believe.
(laughing)
- It is.
- [Kelly] Unbelievable.
But I was, and I had a I had a problem
because of our family life
and things and circumstances
getting my emotions out and so writing.
So it's interesting that you.
- Yes.
Cathartic.
- [Kelly] You teach writing
it's very cathartic
and so I started just writing
and getting things out
and it turned into poetry
and it turned into songs.
And I think, I don't know
I truly do believe if we do this right,
so many beautiful artists are
going to come out of this.
As far as like children,
especially in teenagers
because there's so many emotions going on
and there just needs to be that outlet.
- [Jill] Yeah, exactly.
And that's why I tell parents all the time
get your kids to write about this moment.
They can, you know, do it over video.
They can do it through artwork,
whatever medium they choose
but it will provide catharsis for them.
And we shouldn't forget this moment.
We shouldn't forget it.
We should remember you know
what we learned about ourselves
and use this to reflect on
how we can make things better.
- [Kelly] Yeah, we don't want to forget it
because we also don't
want to repeat it, people.
- [Jill] Yeah, absolutely.
- God bless history.
- [Jill] Yeah.